non-minimalists
how can you declutter family
relationships
that's that might be one of the toughest
relationships to try and declutter
because you know family
um you can't choose who your family is
and those are the people who are you
know
proximity wise or closest to you
especially if you have a family
that gets together a lot like you're
always going to be around
family members and that type of
situation um
for me i think about uh when i first
started
just kind of it wasn't i didn't have any
demands as much as just kind of setting
up boundaries
with different family members and i've
talked about this before with a family
member who
um well i was listening to this
particular family member and another
family family member
having a conversation and
a family but one a family member said to
the other i'm so glad
that we're related because no matter
what i do
you have to love me and it and it hit me
that
a lot of my family members
they don't use family
to strengthen the bond or to strengthen
the love they use it as
a tether yeah as a tether they use it as
like leverage to be like
i can treat you however i want right
because you have to love me
right and maybe i do maybe i do choose
to love you
and but you're mistaking love with
support or encouragement or like or
spending
i can love you from a distance i can
love you and never see you
again but i can still love you
and so in a weird way that family member
was
right in the sense that yeah i will
continue to love you
but that doesn't mean i'll continue to
support you i'll continue
to tolerate your bad behavior
right so i'm not going to continue that
because i don't have to i don't have to
do that in order
to love you you're misunderstanding love
you think that
love means a check mark on the board you
think that
love is a trophy or an achievement
or an obligation no no no no
those things are fine by the way love
can compel me to do any of those things
yeah but i you can't force me to just
because we're family members
right so this family member um
you know basically was talking about you
know why don't we
why don't we uh stay more in touch you
know why don't we
you know what uh why don't we see each
other more often you know you don't go
out of your way to hang out with me
and i really just made this statement of
like you know to be honest i have
friends
who treat me better than you treat me
and they were like well you know that's
that's kind of bs because we're family
and family is a strong bond and
you know family you're supposed to be
closer to your family than anyone else
i said right i was like so wouldn't you
assume that
family would treat that my family would
treat me better than the way my friends
treat me
instead of using it as this obligatory
love
yes and like the light bulb that went
off in this family member's head
was like really and i'll tell you what
from that conversation on
they have never acted the way that i
mean it really changed the way that they
treated me
and what's fascinating about that is you
didn't try to change him no
in a way you weren't even convincing him
what you were simply doing is you were
stating a truth
because you you knew you weren't going
to go i'm going to change you or change
your mind
but you simply stated the truth and that
that provided that floodlight of
awareness
yeah that we were talking about in fact
back to the
romantic relationship that became toxic
for you
what you had there is all of a sudden
off of the drugs you had this floodlight
of awareness
and that that constantly your attention
you're at tension um in that
relationship because
uh you were forced to pay attention to
these
things that were making you miserable
yeah and
of course that's going to create tension
in your body in your mind in your
relationship
in your life but as soon as that flood
light of awareness
you sort of feel that tension drop in a
way yeah
now when that tension drops you realize
like oh i have to create some
distance between me and this
family member basically she was
basically your family right and and so
in a weird way i'll give you a pithy
answer choose your family wisely
and what i mean by that is just because
you share dna
with someone doesn't mean you have to
share time with someone
tweet that podcast sean boom and and
what i'm really saying there is you're
you have no obligations uh
we did a whole it's one of my favorite
podcast episodes we did go back and
listen to the obligations podcast
that we did and realize that all of our
obligations
are self-inflicted obligations and that
includes our obligation
to our family and maybe even you know
of course we're going to have certain
responsibilities if we birth a child
we're going to have an obligation
for that child's safety that's not what
i'm talking about
but when we're talking about any other
adults in our life
and post-pubescent people in our life
yeah
the obligations are wrong the baggage
that we're carrying we get to decide
what's in
that baggage totally and so how do you
declutter
your family relationships it's not about
getting rid of the person it's about
getting rid of the obligations
letting go stop clinging to the
expectations that have been thrust upon
you either by them
or that you've invented on your own yeah
you know one thing that i have observed
um with
my stepdad is
he is a very angry
anytime he feels like a family member is
disrespecting him i mean he just
he becomes an evil person that i mean i
just i've never seen anyone act as evils
as men
but what's interesting is that when he's
out and about
with people he comes across as
kind of a nice guy okay and there are
like my my mom's mom he can have a
conversation with her
and never that evil will never
come out but it's only with
the people that he's closest to
is where that evil comes out and i don't
know what that is about
a piece of me looks at it and thinks
well
if he's evil to you he actually really
loves you
because he has this love
which for some reason he attaches an
expectation to like oh
i love you so therefore you should love
me and if we love each other we will
respect one another
and if he gets if someone disrespects
him
when now his feelings are hurt and then
the evil comes out yes
so so but that's obviously not love no
obviously
right and so what he's doing is he's
conflating that in fact there's a
section in love people use things
where i talk about it's it's odd
but the people that we are we behave the
worst to
are the people who are closest to us
quite often why is that
well uh part of that has to do there's
there are several studies on this
comfort thing with it i guess
part of it has to do with comfort but
part of it also has to do with
those are the people that we've assigned
the
ability to change our own mood yeah
it's my fault anytime i do that so if i
have giving you if i've given you the
power i've
i've given away my my freedom basically
because i'm giving you the power to make
me
mad angry upset sad
if i've given you the power to make me
sad
that's on me but then when you make me
sad
i lash out at you because i gave you
that power
when who's the person that i need to
have be frustrated with
myself for giving away my own freedom
right
giving you that power did you enjoy this
video if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists today
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free